T'as une capote ?
Quoi ?
T'as une capote ou pas ?
Bah non, je crois pas.
Attends, t'en as pas toi ?
Bah non.
Oh merde...
J'ai trop envie de toi...
Bah ouais, moi aussi.
C'est pas grave, on fera demain.
Oh non... Non, non...
Non mais je vais aller au distributeur, j'en ai pour deux secondes.
Ok.
Tu m'attends ?
Bah ouais je suis chez moi, je vais pas bouger.
Ouais...
A toute...
Excusez-moi, je suis désolé, vraiment.
Je suis comme tout le monde.
Non mais allez-y, allez-y, j'ai tout mon temps.
Vous voulez un coup de main, peut-être ?
Attendez, vous savez quoi ? Je vais vous aider, ça ira plus vite.
Voilà.
Je vous prends ça ? C'est bien.
Bonne soirée.
Ah putain !
Attendez ! Monsieur, s'il-vous plaît !
Attendez, parce que la machine marche plus,
est-ce qu'on peut peut-être s'arranger pour les capotes ?!
Bonsoir.
Oh putain...
Ouais...
Bon...
Merci beaucoup, au-revoir.
Vous prenez rien ?
Non, non, en fait, je venais chercher de... de...
La farine de sarrasin, mais vous en avez pas du coup...
Même pas cette boîte de capote ?
Comment vous avez fait ?
Je sais tout sur mon établissement.
Petite merde.
Attendez, c'est peut-être pas la peine de m'insulter non plus.
Allô, la police ?
Je suis en train de me faire braquer par un malade !
Putain ça se voit dans les yeux, il est déterminé !
De quoi ?! Ça va pas ou quoi ?!
Venez vite ! Putain, il m'a pris à la gorge ce fils de pute !
Je peux plus respirer, venez-vite ! Venez-vite !
Tu baiseras pas ce soir.
Vous êtes complétement malade !
J'arrive là, bam ! Bam ! Bam !
Patate dans sa gueule !
Zblah ! Zblah ! Zblah, patate ! Droit dans la tête !
Mais je t'ai dit...
Mais tu m'as dit, t'arrives et tout, tu poses !
Bonsoir !
Excusez-moi de vous déranger, en fait c'est juste que...
Je... J'ai une petite galère.
Vas-y tu veux quoi ? Tu veux un ketru ?
Non, non, non. Enfin si, si en fait...
Je... J'étais avec ma copine
et en fait on avait pas de... protection et du coup je...
Je me demandais si vous auriez pas une petite poteca à dépan'.
Une quoi ?!
Une poteca... Une capote.
Vas-y, vas-y, fais-lui une faciale wesh, ça ira plus vite.
Ça te fait pas rire ?
Pourquoi tu rigoles pas, toi ?
Mon pote il a sorti une blague, tu rigoles pas ?
Ah ouais ? Mais si...
Il m'a dit "si", wesh...
Vas-y dégage, là ! Sale shlag, là !
Qu'est-ce tu fais, là ? Pourquoi tu l'as frappé, là ?
Je sais pas... Je le trouvais beau en fait...
Quoi ?!
Je savais pas comment lui dire... C'est...
Enlève-ta main ! Mais qu'est-ce que tu me... De quoi tu me...
Eddy, je crois que je suis un émotif.
Mais ferme-ta gueule ! Je veux pas le sav...
Mais t'es chelou, vas-y, vas-y...
Je vais au distributeur, j'en ai pour deux secondes...
Monsieur s'il-vous plaît !
On peut peut-être s'arranger pour les capotes ?!
Tu baiseras pas ce soir.
Vas-y dégage, là ! Sale shlag !
Hé ! T'as pas une pièce ?
Si, mais j'en ai vraiment besoin là, je suis vraiment désolé.
Ouais c'est ça, ouais.
Bonsoir. Excusez-moi, je suis désolé de vous déranger,
vous auriez pas un préservatif à me dépanner ?
En fait, j'ai ma copine qui m'attend, ça fait deux heures que je suis parti, j'ai plus
de batterie, j'ai même pas pu lui envoyer de message, elle doit être en panique là.
Il faut vraiment que je lui fasse l'amour.
Franchement si vous avez ça vous me sauveriez la vie,
parce que là elle doit me prendre pour un con, elle doit se dire que...
Calme-toi.
Bouge-pas.
Nervurée.
Quoi ?
Ça c'est des capotes nervurées.
Avec ça, ta copine elle va s'envoler au paradis.
Voilà.
Merci.
Avec plaisir.
Merci beaucoup, hein.
T'y vas à fond, hein.
Ouais.
Merci !
Champion !
Je vais aux croissants, moi.
Semaine prochaine ?
Hé !
T'aurais pas une pièce ?
Si, carrément.
Oh !
Alors-là, viens que je t'embrasse mon vieux.
Oh la la, je suis désolé.
Je t'en ai mis... Ouais y'en a un peu quoi...
C'est pas grave. Non mais c'est pas grave.
Je suis désolé. Ça tournait...
Tiens, t'as qu'à garder ça.
Oh bah non...
Garde-ça, aussi.
Oh non, non ça me gêne.
Tiens, tu sais quoi ?
Oh, t'es sérieux ?
Ouais, je m'en fous.
Non, bah arrête-tes conneries.
Non, non ça me fait plaisir.
Oh bah c'est gentil...
Tiens.
Bonne soirée !
T'inquiète, pas de soucis !
Merci, hein !
Merci à toi !
Attends, wesh...
T'es beau, wesh...
Il s'est barré, putain, fait chier...
J'étais à ça de l'avoir...
Gabrielle, j'ai trouvé une capote !
On va pouvoir baiser !
Et en plus, elle est nervurée !
Bon bah... Ben, maman.
Maman, Ben.
L'avantage avec les soirées poker...
C'est que je reviens avec les crois...
Je reviens...
Avec les... Les croissants...
Ah bah d'accord...
Mot compte-triple. Vous avez bien fait d'hésiter, Benjamin.
Merci...
Nervurée...